bonjour garcimore que c'est gentil de
venir me rendre visite
j'avais pas encore et oui non mais je
vois pas qui a préparé un petit top
secret
on a une cuve puis il y en a une boîte
transparente alors l'aider il est
traversé pour les deux couples ont un
prix
alors il vous propose d'essayer
d'enlever le 10 mai sans laisser les
boues découleront c'est à dire que vous
souhaiterez comme ça mais ce n'est comme
ça oui
le 2 juin mais c'est quoi le choisit
lenny wilkens cat et moi j'ai pas très
dur m'a heurté de plein fouet les
réponses générales qui fait partie de
mes 5 vous lâchez les boues découleront
at il dit pour arriver mais je tire pas
moi donc voilà c'est encore plus
difficile mais c'est un petit bout comme
ça et notre désir est attaché les deux
vous que ce sera encore plus difficile
qu'est ce qu'il a fait dans le vol de
deux il me prépare quelque chose de
galloway devait sortir le 10 décembre
chez les bouts de corde on regarde bien
il sait qui sera ce qu'elle est le plus
long que l'autre
oui j'avais beaucoup pour moi
valverde fait un sacré bout de course
mais c'est peut-être non non non moi je
ne pense plus rien avec vous merci moi
vraiment je me garde bien de faire quoi
que ce soit
obama souffre et ne me dites pas de
souffle et non plus franchement
maintenant le champ aux
c'est très joli
c'est très très joli voilà ça c'est
votre santé le petit cadeau de garcimore
à toutes les mamans c'est qu'il a
préparé à l'école cette semaine en place
[Musique]